hercule poirot pythagore et angèle sont
des chats végétalien dans leur
croquettes pas de viande de poisson 2 ou
de produits laitiers leurs maîtresses et
vegan comme je suis préoccupé par le
sort des êtres sensibles des animaux en
général je trouve très contradictoires
disons de déshabiller pierre pour
habiller paul de tuer un animal pour en
ouvrir un autre qui elle n'est pas la
seule à penser ainsi
on a quand même un ton bon une bonne
variété de produits au niveau de la
galerie de l'os dentaire dans le vg
depuis deux ans l'offre explose de plus
en plus de propriétaires de chiens
convertissent leur animal c'est leur
mode de vie souvent jetta ou sinon
vraiment le souci dans les rhodes de
l'environnement à fond car les chats et
les chiens dévore la viande d'élevage ce
qui contribuent à polluer la planète
seulement au canada les ventes
d'aliments pour ces deux animaux de
compagnie représentent près de 2
milliards de dollars pour produire une
livre de boeuf veau faire va falloir
utiliser plus de 9000 litres d'eau
tandis que pour produire une idée grille
on sait pas plus que quatre le dos
l'entreprise wilders ailleurs fondé en
2015 vend des gâteries pour chiens
concocté à partir d'insectes
elle vient de lancer une nourriture à
base de mouches quand on a lancé
entreprises qu'on a lancé nos premiers
produits
on sentait vraiment qu'on poussait un
nouveau produit de nouvelles idées puis
une nouvelle façon de consommer dans ce
qu'elle a de plus en plus cette année
même l'année dernière on sent qu'il ya
une traction qui vient du marché oui
mais c'est bon ou pas le vg pour les
chiens et les chats pour un chat c'est
pour est possible d'être végétarien
c'est extrêmement difficile de balancer
la diète c'est pour recommander le chien
vraiment un carnivore attendant un petit
peu omnivore on peut aller jouer là
dessus mais le show car manque en bourse
très valérie giroud assure que ces chats
végétalien depuis sept ans sont en bonne
santé
ici marie-eve cousineau radio-canada à
montréal